you want to hear something that's going
to blow your mind $1 million in profit
from less than 6,000 Instagram followers
what I want to walk you through is a
story of a business owner that I just
recently met doing those exact numbers
from a tiny audience and what you can
use from those strategies for yourself
to get started making big money even if
you have a small audience I had the most
insane thing happened last night and it
has had me at a loss for words I was
actually at a loss for words like
speechless befuddled bewildered and I
was like what is going on and it took a
concept that I kind of believe in and
I've made some moves around it and it
took it to the absolute hyperbolic
extreme that you could imagine and it's
still held true and I think that for
business owners who are listening to
this for people who make content who are
listening to this but just in this is
going to I mean it it has it has
slightly nudged how I see the world and
I'll just put it that way and I feel
like a lot of the beliefs I have around
the world are still relatively
I I I hold on I believe them pretty
pretty strongly so here's what happened
so um we had a company come in um and
the the the lady who owns the company is
a registered dietitian and I'm not going
to shout her I would shout her out
because I want her to get all the Kudos
in the world but I don't want it to mess
up what she's doing and so that's why
I'm going to keep it Anonymous so she's
a registered dietician she takes home
just under a million dollars a year
helping other registered dieticians Bill
Insurance correctly and so it's super
niche in terms of what she's really good
at so she knows how to be an RD and help
people Bill Insurance codes properly and
so the average uh I think dietitian adds
like $100,000 in income using just like
her kind of coding system for billing
them right crazy Niche crazy crazy Niche
and so um I spent I spent some time with
her we talked about her business and
things I was like hey I think you move
this stuff around and I think that the
business could probably do about 3
million a year to 5 million a year in
profit if she just moved some of the
things around that we talked about and
so I was like cool this is great and so
we had dinner and I was like hey let me
see your your your your Instagram so I
just wanted to pull it up because I was
going to make a point about something
because I assumed that she had like I
wanted to see what kind of con that she
had assumed that she had at least a
relatively large following I honestly
hadn't looked shame on me and this is
what happens I pull it up number one her
account is not verified and I'm like
this is your number one source of income
and you were not paying $4.99 a month
like what are you doing what are you
doing and I after after yelling at her
for that I then was then drawn to the
next natural absolutely unbelievable
thing that I'm going to say to you she
had
5,800 followers her average post got 19
likes and like one comment and
100% 100% of her acquisition came from
her organic Instagram with just under
6,000 followers I pulled up her account
stats because I was losing my mind
seeing the amount of sales that she was
making off of this account her her
account her reach for 30 days of her
account was
2,800 that was her reach 2800 like for
context I do about 20 million a month
context and I was
like what is happening right now like
what am I what do I not what is what is
going on how is this possible and so
she's doing 10 plus sales a day at a low
ticket price and doing 3ish sales a week
at a higher ticket price and when I say
higher ticket I'm talking like you know4
$5,000 um type price point and then a
lower ticket thing for just like some
cheat sheets of like here's all the
codes and this is how you can do them
whatever and a 10 a day a
day okay and so this this is that's
that's the big story now I'm going to
zoom out and I'm going to say what I
think is so cool about this so she says
this and I was like how how how are you
doing this and she's like you know what
I I got my first sale when I had eight
people on my email list eight
eight and I was like that's nuts and she
was like yes it was really confirming
for me that like there people were
listening and so I was like well how big
is your email list now and she's been
doing this for a few years I've not I
told 2,900 people on our email list
and she makes sales for
emails and it was such a great reset for
me it was such a good nudge as a
reminder that the view count you have on
the other side the 19 likes like there's
a real person on the other side of this
that is watching your clip that has five
views there's a real person who's
opening up your emails when you have a
list that has 300 people on it like
people are watching people are listening
and the thing that was unique that I
found about her I'll say two things and
I think that there's a really good meta
concept here one is she her content was
consistent and she said yeah I do one
post and I do one story every day and I
like but she was like super proud of it
I was like this is adorable and also
crazy but the posts that she talks about
100% of them are about billing insurance
as a registered dietician like could not
be more Niche couldn't like you couldn't
even think of one right
for I couldn't even imagine one and
despite that she's making the sales that
she is and so I'm going to zoom out on
this because I think it's really
interesting so if you if you go to my
Alex's homepage right like as a user of
Instagram my user page I've showed this
to people because people are like this
is really weird all I have is philosophy
stuff comedy and gym equipment like
that's my whole feed I have no news I
have it's philosophy comedy and gym
equipment because that's what I look at
and what's interesting is that the
philosophy is kind of a lot of those are
kind of like midsize the comedy
comedians are mass market so a lot of
those guys are bigger but I get tiny
comedians like 5,000 follower 10,000
follower comedians get shown to me all
the time because Instagram knows I like
comedy and equipment dealers and
Equipment manufacturers and metal
fabricators not always the best
marketers and so like the these accounts
that I follow there have like 500 a
th000 like 2,000 like they're not huge
accounts but I get served everything in
that space on Instagram because that's
what I'm into
and so I think that there's a couple
really interesting things here one is
that I think that Niche content will
make you a hell of a lot more money if
that's what you're actually selling and
I have here's the thing I have learned
this lesson twice so I like to you know
I like to pretend that I'm you know I uh
I like to think I'm a fancy businessman
who learns all these lessons but I I
have messed this up two times not two
times and so I tell the story about how
my podcast was getting you know two
3,000 downloads uh per month which is
like 100 downloads an episode not a lot
right but and that was for like a few
years but I don't tell you this other
part of the story which is that my
podcast started growing in numbers when
I started talking about General business
it also started growing in numbers even
faster once we sold the company for gym
launch but there was a period of about
18 months prior to me selling where I
just talked about General business
because I was like I'm tired of talking
about gyms I just want to talk about
business in general during that period
of time our organic sales went to
basically
zero and it took us like six months to
figure out that the reason that that had
happened was because I stopped talking
about gym [__] and gym owners were like
less interested in my content than
generic business cont do that make sense
like if you if you're just if you're a
business owner you're going to listen to
business stuff in general if you're a
dentist then you're going to get a lot
out of a dentist only podcast right but
there's not that many dentists so you're
not going to get a lot of listens but
the listens in terms of relevancy is
going to be through the roof and so we
started making less sales but I was
getting more views more listens right
now I ended up wanting to go in that
direction so it was fine and I'm talking
about General business now right I made
that mistake second time not necessarily
a mistake we learned right um three to
six months ago we were like let's
experiment with some wider content and
by experimenting with wider content we
sure as hell got more views more more a
bunch of other vanity metrics but the
number of business owners that was
watching and the way I I measured that
was uh our cpms on our videos on YouTube
the amount of people who opt in it out
acis.com people who buy our books all of
those all of those metrics were actually
down despite our views being up and so
this little story that I have of the
dinner that I had last night blew me
away because it just showed how much you
can really make if you have a DieHard
audience that doesn't need to be big
less than 6,000 followers her account
reaches less than 2,800 accounts per
month and she's taking home almost a
million dollars a year that's income not
Revenue I'm just talking profit and
right now if she just take makes the
couple of obious VI changes that she can
make she'll probably make somewhere in
the $3 to5 million a year range income
income and if you're looking to make
your first dollar online or monetize
your audience no matter what the size is
school.com games is the easiest way that
I know how to do it I take a call once a
week inside of that Community to answer
questions for people who are getting
started I have a step-by-step course
that lays out what exactly to do to make
your first dollar online and once a
month I drop 8 hours of training from
the top 10 community business owners
showing exactly what they're doing to
scale their communities today school.com
s/ games you can start for free and I
say this because there's there's two
angles on this right on on one side
people are like well I don't want to
start making content because what if I
have low numbers I believe now the
algorithms are so good that if you make
it about one specific type of thing it's
going to show it to those people and
right now Al by the way like the guy who
runs uh Instagram talked about he's
actually favoring smaller creators now
so that's a good thing if you're if
you're trying to get into it but beyond
that I think there's so much power in
and when I talked to her she's like I
just want to show up she's like I show
up whether there's no one there's one
person and I just I I show like like
it's a whole Auditorium she said this
thing and I have just noticed this with
[__] winners right it's like they're
doing it because of what they because
she's a missionary she just genuinely
wants to help regro dietician she's like
I get it I worked at the hospital do 100
hours a week and like I was under you
know under staffed underbuild and I had
to start making this business work on my
own doing one day a week so I had to
figure out how to do this quickly in
terms of all this spilling stuff and
she's she gets so passionate when she
was talking about it I I've confidence
she's not going to change industry she
been in 20-some years like she's not
going anywhere she loves this stuff and
the people who stay in the game the
longest like the game they're in and so
I have this thing that I I I heard from
last dance which is the Michael Jordan
documentary which if you haven't seen
you should totally see it and they're
they're interviewing Jordan and they're
like why do you br you like you bring
such a high intensity every single time
you show up to the arena and he says
this line and I remember getting ch when
I heard it he was like I just never know
I know that there's one guy who's
bringing his son and they saved up for
months to go to this one Bulls game and
that's the one it's not going to be some
prime time night it's just going to be a
random Tuesday game in a series he's
like and that's the only time they're
going to see me play in their lives he's
like and I want I want to perform for
them for that kid for that for that Dad
who wants to impress his son and like
that that like I almost get choked up
when I tell that story because um like
that's so real for me um and the way
that she brought the energy like the
energy she brought in terms of how she
wanted to show up when there's eight
people on her live or two people on her
live or when there were eight people on
her email list and she made her first
$39 sale I was like this is real and
people need to hear this which is why I
wanted to tell the story because I think
it's absolutely insane and it just it
put like I say what I say right which is
hey guys like start making you know
start making content start promoting
yourself if more people know about your
stuff you're going to make more money
period period fight me right that's
that's what it is but you just forget
sometimes that like when you have 10
views on a YouTube video that's 10
people and I remember when I was in the
gym world if I had 10 people that I
could talk to I was stoked right in the
fact that we can do this from home
behind a camera my God how amazing is
that and so like if I had 25 people my
God that's like that's like a talk
that's like a that's like a workshop you
a lunch and learn that you do as a
business owner try and get business the
fact that you can make a niche content
Instagram will serve it to only people
who very interested in that I only like
gym equipment and I get gym equipment
stuff all the time got like 13 likes on
it but I see it right I see it because
Instagram knows and the algorithms only
get better and so um I wanted to cover
all that stuff because I thought it was
really important um and from a from a
how do you how do you make this she has
endless sources of content because she
just literally answers their questions
they just keep she was like I was like
so where do you get stuff for she's like
oh they all have questions and so I just
I just make my posts answering their
questions that's it and I will say this
I think she could do a lot of things
better to be clear but like she just had
every other post just had a by the way
there's a link in my bio that has more
stuff that you might
like that was it that was the whole
strategy and she was doing a million
dollars a year take-home just under and
so I was just blown away by this and I I
find it actually one of the most hopeful
messages that I have seen in in person
in a very long time and so people have
you know like unless I have 100,000
followers not be able to make money
unless I have T the thing is is that
people seek the followers with the idea
that the followers are going to make
them Rich the followers will make you
famous understanding business will make
you rich she understands business she's
like I'm just going to talk to the
people that I want to serve and I'm only
going to serve them and I'm going to
answer all the questions and the way she
talked about she's like I just want to
be useful she's like I just want to help
him out and so if you're coming into the
frame rather than like I want this piece
of content to perform and think there's
eight people on either side I just want
them to be better off and hopefully
answer their question from this piece of
content they making you will get raving
fans even if your audience is 5,000
people but there's a there's a book I
can't remember the guy who wrote the
name of the book but he says you only
need a thousand true fans and I think
that so like a thousand fan like you can
you can do whatever you want with a
thousand fans even at 10 bucks a month
right like you can make $100,000 a year
if you just do that right thousand true
fans that are die hard and you can make
a lot more than that with a thousand
true fans and so people think because we
have this 8 billion people in the world
that you need to be you need to be the
Barack need to be Kim Kardashian need to
be Mr Beast and sure with massive
numbers like those like you're going to
get famous those things are are required
but like you can make an absolute
killing just talking about what you're
really good at and that's the other
piece here is that I I'm I'm half I'm
shatting this at myself too which is
like we we we made piece of marriage
content a couple you know a couple
relationship stuff a little bit of
Fitness stuff and the thing is is
like there's there's no relationship
billionaire like the the only objective
measure of if your marriage is good just
from a society standpoint is that you
are not divorced that's it and then it's
that measured by how many years you put
up with each
other that's it and I don't like that
because it's one of those it's one of
those crappy things where everybody's
been in a relationship so everybody has
an opinion and there's no objective
proof that one thing is better than
another and so like I hate I don't like
making content in that space we tried it
out because like we have a unique
relationship Lea and I and we like what
we do and it's worked for us well but um
I would say that I have more credibility
uh in business and so she has
credibility in not just she doesn't talk
about nutrition at all she just talks
about how to be a restro dietician and
Bill Insurance properly and get
credentialed and do this whole process
that apparently is a big pain in the
butt and so if you are somebody who has
a very specific Niche that you're that
you're good at I would highly encourage
you to just make the content that gets
40 views that gets 100 likes that you
know for sure will help a very specific
person because when you do help that
very specific person they will like you
a lot more than many people who like you
a little bit and the people who like you
a lot are the ones who buy from you and
that's the thing and I I I'm making this
because I need to remind myself of this
which is like you can either be rich or
you can be famous you can obviously be
both but honestly sometimes it's a lot
faster to just just get rich and many of
you get in the game because you want to
make money from social media from making
content from things like that from
advertising the business you want to do
more of that get your face out there
whatever but you start chasing the views
because the views is what the algorithm
right encourages but the business side
this is why I'm trying to make this
point is that the metrics don't
necessarily follow the van your business
metrics don't follow your vanity metrics
there and so just because you get more
views doesn't mean you get more Revenue
just because you get more subs doesn't
mean you get more optins right for your
website or for whatever it is that you
that you sell you don't get sales from
that stuff subscribers don't mean sales
and so there are there are tons of
stories of tiny channels we have uh we
have an insurance brokerage that we own
um and the the the head of the insurance
brokerage has like when when we when we
invest in the company had I think like
5,000 followers on Instagram or Sor not
on Instagram on on YouTube and the
business is doing many millions of
dollarss a year I'll just be that be
very clear there many millions not just
one or two and it's because he talks
about a very complex structure of
insurance that that he specializes in
he's one of the foremost experts and his
videos get like 100 to 500 views but
those 100 to 500 views are people who
are looking for incredibly high-end very
specialized Insurance
products and so don't be afraid of the
empty
room very low views doesn't mean low
Revenue it just means that it's more
specific
and that you're talking to a more
specific person and a specific problem
being solved for a specific person is
how you make big
money and
so I want I thought this was one of the
most hopeful messages that I had seen in
real life in a long time and it was
really confirming for me it also doubled
down on the direction that we're doing
which for those you said I said mistake
made the mistake twice um we have come
back to going back to business baby only
business uh only Alex only business only
for the fans just kidding um and uh and
I I hope you I hope this at least
encouraged you to just divorce yourself
more and more from the vanity metrics
around it because I am now leaning so
hard to this because our business
metrics and I have a big long thing
that's coming out soon um have
skyrocketed since we stopped going
anything that's not business and so I
feel so confirmed in this direction that
I want to encourage as many of you as
humanly possible to just toss out the
vanity metrics because they do not
[__] matter if you're trying to make
money if you're just trying to get
famous then yeah but I means it's great
metric for fame right um and so yeah
just do that be willing to have a th000
fans make stuff that has 19 likes
because you know that the 19 people who
liked it were like this was unbelievable
for me and they will take the next step
and they will purchase from your
business keep being awesome have an
amazing day bye